[Música]
hace último vengo obsesionada contando
historias de mujeres científicas me
encanta la primera que se me apareció
obvio marie curie no le dieron un premio
nobel le dieron dos así que se merece su
pedestal pero hay muchas otras que no se
ganaron un premio nobel pero hicieron
cosas increíbles hace poco me enteré de
la historia de eugenia sacerdote eugenia
era una médica italiana que emigró
argentina
en la época de la segunda guerra hizo
grandes aportes entre ellos el más
importante fue la que trajo la vacuna
salk contra la polio en los años 50
gracias a ella se salvaron miles de
vidas
yo soy científica y más o menos desde el
2002 que trabajo en la universidad
haciendo investigación
eugenia trabajó activamente hasta el
2004 y dicen que era como muy copada que
vos podías ir a hablar con ella y saben
que se murió en el 2011 tenía 101 años
yo me enteré de ese hace muy poco
como ve la perdiz no se dará una idea la
bronca que eso me dio haberme enterado
de ella hace muy poco muchísima bronca
por eso yo cuento historias de mujeres
científicas para homenajear a las que se
fueron pero sobre todo para no perdernos
a las que están muchas gracias
[Música]